the queen and the duke of edinburgh will
spend christmas quietly in windsor
buckingham palace has said let's bring
in our royal correspondent rhiannon
mills now and a break in tradition
for the royal family uh like for so many
of us this christmas rhiannon
that's right and it's interesting isn't
it when you've just been having that
debate
about whether we should all be spending
time together and
i think for the royal family of course
it's really important right
throughout this pandemic they've been
setting the right examples so i think
you've got a couple of things going on
here first of all
of course for the queen and the duke of
edinburgh there's been this protective
bubble around them right throughout the
pandemic
so in some ways it's not surprising that
it's been announced that
rather than going to sandringham rather
than spending time with other people and
potentially family members in
sandringham
they've decided they are going to spend
christmas at windsor quietly
but also of course you can't forget that
every year on christmas morning
thousands of people normally gather at
sandringham to watch
the royal family head to church a huge
group of the royal family
and i think for uh the queen and for the
duke of edinburgh it's also important
for them that they're not seem to be
encouraging crowds of people to gather
outside of sandringham
to enjoy that annual tradition of
watching the royals go to church i've
also just heard that apparently the
queen won't be going to church
on christmas morning there'll be no way
of us filming or taking photographs of
her and again that is because they don't
want to
encourage people to gather this is a
huge break in tradition it's 33 years
since they last it didn't go to
sandringham it is worth pointing out
though before they used to go
to sandringham it was actually windsor
where the royals used to spend
uh christmas anyway so in some ways the
queen of princeville of course will
remember at those celebrations back in
windsor
but we know that they hugely enjoy their
time at sandringham it's a really
important
moment when all the family can usually
get together
we have been told they are likely to see
some family members at some point
over christmas we're not being told
exactly who and when
we also understand that the prince of
wales and the duchess of cornwall are
actually going to spend christmas at
high grove but they hope to see the
queen
and the duke of edinburgh at windsor at
some point uh at the moment though it's
not been confirmed exactly what prince
william and kate and the kids going to
be doing for christmas
but yeah as you said like many of us uh
the family the royals
are going to have to spend christmas
very differently this year